翻訳: YAYOI ITO
校正: Mizuho WATANABE
こんにちは
北海道 小樽でガラスを作っています
木村幸愛（ゆきえ）と申します
今日は制作の格好で
吹き竿も持ってきました
こんなとこで喋ることなんて
もちろんありませんので
これ持ってたら なんとか正気を保てるかなと
思って持ってきたんですけど
（笑）
今日は どうなるかわかりませんが
宜しくお願いします
（拍手）
私がやっているのは宙吹きガラスと申します
およそ1,200度でガラスを溶かしていて
そして 24時間そのガラスを
溶かし続けています
この竿の先に そのガラスを巻いてきて
紙リンと呼ばれる 新聞紙を畳んで ―
水で濡らしたものを掌の上に乗せて
それで形を成形していきます
よく「熱くないですか？」と聞かれるんですが
掌は熱くないです
ただ 1,200度のガラスなんで
紙リンの水分が一気に沸騰して
手に垂れてきた時は
紙リンを投げ出してしまうぐらい
めちゃくちゃ熱いです
それ以外は 手で触れないので
金属のジャックと呼ばれる道具や
ピンセットの大っきな
ピンサーと呼ばれる道具で
指先の代わりに摘まんだり 引っ張ったり
ねじったり
そんな感じで作っています
制作の時は
ディスコミュージックなんかを掛けて
ノリノリで作ってます
服装も大体こんな感じで
ちょっと今日は ええ方のやつ
着て来ましたけど
（笑）
楽しく作っています
そしてどんなものを作っているかと言いますと
例えば 小樽の海をイメージしたペンダントとか
ハートを閉じ込めたペンダントとか
あとは ハートをモチーフにした飾り瓶とか
カラフルな透明色をたくさん使ったお皿とか
グラスとか
花器とか
アロマポットとか
あとはオブジェなんかも作ったりとか
トロフィーなんかも
制作依頼を受けて作ったりしています
ガラスは ただの何でもない塊だけでも
すごく綺麗ですので
いつもそれには負けたくないと思っています
私が手を加えることによって
もっと綺麗に もっと魅力的になれば ―
そう思いながら作っています
私は 大阪出身で
高校時代まで大阪で過ごしました
ガラスを始めるようになったきっかけは
高校時代の恩師が 吹きガラス工場に
連れて行ってくれたことでした
そこには真ん中に大っきな釜があって
ゴーゴーと火が燃えていて
その真っ赤な火を前に
真剣に立ち向かう職人さんを見て
率直に わあ凄い めっちゃ格好いい
と思ったのが最初の印象でした
そこで初めて溶けたガラスを
触らせてもらったんですけど
トロトロで 熱すぎて
何も もちろんできませんでした
でもその時に見た 溶けたガラスは
オレンジ色に静かに発光していて
それがものすごく綺麗で
そんな魅力みたいなものが忘れられなくて
一人で職人の世界に
飛び込んでみることにしました
周りからは
「あんたそんな 続かへんから止めとき」
「そんな寒いとこ行って
あんた寒がりなのにどないすんの」
と言われたんですけど
18歳の希望に燃えた私を誰も止められず
一人で小樽にやって来ました
ちょっと話は変わるんですけど
小学校の時から空手を始めまして
中学の時には全国で２位になりました
（拍手）
すごく負けず嫌いで
１番になりたいと思ってたんです
正直 ガラスを始める時も
若かったですし 世間知らずでしたし
「もしかしたら これやったら
１番なれるんちゃうやろか？」
なんて思ってたんですけど
そんな根拠のない自信みたいなものは
その後 速攻でズタボロになりました
職人の世界に
飛び込んだはいいんですけど
その世界は 私が想像してたよりも
遥かに厳しい世界でした
どんどん つらくなっていって
頑張ってはいたんですけど
毎日しんどくなって
当時は携帯電話も持ってなかったですし
雪の中 公衆電話から電話するんですけど
テレホンカードの数字が
みるみる減っていきますし
近くに話ができる友達も居なかったですし
家族には弱音は吐きたくなかったですし
そんな感じで精神的にも
けっこう追い詰められていって
しんどくなっていったんですけど
ふっと見える小樽の海の景色には
何度か心を救われたのを覚えています
ここまで近くに海とかは無かったので
「あー 海ってええなぁ」と思いました
そんなところで
ギリギリで頑張ってはいたんですけど
やっぱり挫折してしまいました
職人の世界に飛び込んで
２年で辞めてしまいました
でもその時
ここは辞めても
ガラスは絶対に止めないぞと
それだけは心に誓っていました
そして大阪に帰って
また新たな場所で
ガラスに携われることになったんです
職人の世界は
見て覚えろっていうものだったんですけど
正直 見てはいたんですけど
自分のことで精一杯で
でも ガラスを
窯から巻いては持っていく —
ガラスを巻いては持っていく というのを
毎日繰り返していたので
その部分だけは 次に働いた先の
大阪の先輩も認めてくれたんです
先輩に「お前 ガラス巻いてくんのだけは
天下一品やな」と
「こんなトロトロのガラス
なかなか扱えれる奴はおれへんぞ」と
「そやのに２年もやってて
なんでコップの１個も作られへんねん」
と言われました
そうか 私はコップの１個も作れないんだと
改めて気付かされました
そしてその先輩が
自分でガラスを巻いてきて
自らコップを作ってくれるのを
言葉で全部説明してくれたんです
「ここは この時に こうやから
ここで こう冷ますんや」
とか そんな感じで
そうすると今まで見て覚えてきたものが
頭の中にパズルのピースみたいに
あったんですけど
それが言葉で教えてもらったことによって
一気にババババっと組み上がっていきました
そしてスッと一気に
理解できるようになったんです
その後からはコップが
すらっと作れるようになったんです
これは自分でもとても気持ちのいい体験でした
そして それからは ―
これやったら
なんでも作れるんちゃうかなと思いまして
色んなものに挑戦していくようになりました
その時に —
初めてガラスが楽しいと
思えるようになったんです
それまで私にとってガラスは
つらいものでしかなかったので
そして場所を横浜の方にも移しまして
経験を重ねていきまして
30歳の時に夫の故郷でもある
小樽に戻ってきて
自分の工房を作るために
戻ってくることになりました
場所も決まって
アメリカから溶解炉も輸入して
「ギャラリーオープンや！」と
気合いを入れてたんですけど
溶解炉は稼働から５日目で
いきなり壊れました
えーっ！てなって
もうどうしようとなって
新聞にもオープンの日を
載せてもらってましたし
どうしよう？となって
泣きながら
夫と一緒に食べた焼きそばの味は
今でも忘れられないです
そんなこと あったんですけど
なんとかオープンすることができました
家族とか知人とか友人の支えがありまして
そして 私が独立すると腹をくくって
これで生きていくと決めた時から
家族の態度も
変わってきたような気がするんです
特に父は大阪から小樽に来る度に
ギャラリーの中の机なんかを
夫を一番弟子にして 作っていってくれています
ギャラリーの棚も
２人で仲良く作ってくれたりして
そして夫は父の一番弟子に加え
私の専属アシスタントにもなって
工房での作業も
ずっと一緒にやってくれています
夫はそれまでガラスは
やったことはなかったんですよね
そして大阪の母や妹 —
小樽の夫の母も
内職や経理なんかで
手伝ってくれるようになりまして
私の独立が 家族の共通の
話題になるというのは
最初から意図していたことでは
ありませんでした
ガラスを始めた頃は
一人でガラスを頑張って
いつか家を建てたら
みんなが幸せになれるんちゃうかなとか
そんなようなことを思ってたんですけど
私の想像しないところで
家族の絆は深まっているように思います
そして今ではもう一つ
ガラスを続ける理由が増えたような気がします
「プロポーズに使いたい
大切な瞬間なので協力して欲しい」
遠方から「年に一度の楽しみ」
と言って来てくださる方
「あなたを見てると
小さい頃に体が不自由になった娘が
元気だったら という姿を想像する」
力強い握手と共に「あなたを応援してる」
と言ってくれた おばあさま
そして届く手紙
いつからか ガラスを作ることで
随分と人様の人生に
触れることになっていました
そして人様の人生に触れることは
正直 楽しい事ばかりではないです
つい去年も こんな出来事がありました
釧路の村上さん
この方はギャラリーをオープンしたての頃
ギャラリーを開けても誰も来てくれない
そんな時に
「雑誌を見て素敵と思って来たのよ」
と言って 来てくださいました
「あなたの赤を見ると元気になるのよ」
って言ってくださいました
村上さんは長い間 癌と闘病されていました
「本当はね つらい時はたくさんあるのよ
でも あなたのアクセサリーをつけて
病院に行くと
お出かけみたいでウキウキできるから」
って言ってくださいました
毎年 北海道が桜で満開になる
一番季節のいい時に
旦那様と共にギャラリーに
訪れてくださいました
去年の春 いらっしゃらないので
どうしたのかなと思って電話してみると
既に亡くなられていました
悲しくて涙が出ました
ガラスをやっていなければ
こんな悲しみを味わうことも
なかったのかなとさえ思いました
でも 村上さんが下さった温かさは
私は生涯忘れることはないと思っています
喜びも悲しみも全て受け止めていきたい
そう思える出来事でした
何かを作る理由 続ける理由
何を作るかというのは
私は変わっていっていいと思っています
また 変わっていくもんなんじゃないかと
思っています
よく 将来何を作りたいですかって
聞かれることがあるんですけど
私はこの答えにいつも困ってしまいます
というのも 将来作りたい物は
その未来にならないと
きっとわからないような気がするんです
今 作ってる物や
取り組んでいる物の積み重ねが
きっと未来の自分を変えていくと思っています
そんな未来が楽しみになるような
挑戦をしていきたいと思っています
ガラスを始めた頃は １番になりたいという
向こう見ずな理由でした
そして挫折をした後は 意地で続けてました
ガラスの技術の習得にワクワクして
続けてきた時もありましたし
習得技術がついてきた頃からは
次はどんな表現をしてみようかなと
いつも考えてるような気がします
これからもガラスを作る理由は
変わり続けると思っています
でも最初に ―
「ガラスをやりたい！」
「これや！」
と思った時の そのスパークリングな気持ち
それだけはずっと信じ続けたいと思っています
だから私はガラスにこだわっています
いつか海の見える場所に工房をつくって
これからも もっともっと 人の心に
響くような作品を作り続けていきたい
それが今の私の夢です
今日はどうもありがとうございました
（拍手）